volete vedere una cosa disgustosa prego
opposizioni cazzo ditemi voi se questo
individuo non lo prenderei a calci nelle
gengive dalla mattina alla sera con
quegli schifo di capelli unti tipolo
cuore gli occhiali perennemente storti
quello sono io
al primo anno di liceo perché fingevo di
essere guido bagatta noi ne ho idea
probabilmente un ictus ma nonostante
avessi questa forma sovraumana ho avuto
la enorme fortuna di capitare in una
classe è normale e dico è enorme fortuna
perché molti ragazzi questa fortuna non
ce l'hanno parliamo appunto di bullismo
di solito non tratto argomenti così
delicati perché non sono la persona
giusta ma mi sono sinceramente rotto di
continuare a sentire sui giornali di
ragazzi che si suicidano per un insulto
di troppo per me che anni che tratto con
ragazzi di tutte le età
questa cosa è spaventosa nel mio periodo
e si parla di circa dieci anni fa il
bullo anche se non si chiama così ormai
da anni era quello che vestiva tutto
firmato con il cappellino appena appena
appoggiata in testa che fumava sulla
scala antincendio capito si fumava sulla
scala anti incendio
cazzo un genio il cui scopo era soltanto
quello di pagare il più possibile per il
vestiario e più pagava più si sentiva
migliore degli altri probabilmente per
compensare il fatto di avere un pene
piccolissimo non lo so però è l ironico
perché avevano tutti un enorme testa di
cazzo forse per quello che appoggiavano
appena appena il cappello in testa ma
questi individui a parte qualche
rarissimo caso non erano il tipo di
bullo violento
no no no lui è quello che cerca di
essere migliore e diverso dagli altri
creando un gruppo di cloni anche qui
genio facendo sentire tutti gli altri
inferiori e io sono lì che pensavo
perché mai dovrei sentirmi inferiore se
tu hai le scarpe da 300 euro e io no voi
con le scarpe li benissimo a me non
frega nulla ma con quel ragionamento
questo ti porta a essere meglio di me
rosso e fa tappa a ecco mi sembrava
infatti che fine hanno fatto invece quei
bulletti che ti spintonavano i corridoi
della scuola
credo si siano estinti nella generazione
grease dei nostri genitori fiume
rimanere sempre super stereotipati tipo
cappotto di pelle canotta bianca e
capelli tutti in gelati all'indietro
tipo cantante degli anni 40 che ti
prende per le caviglie ti scuote
svuotando tillett aste l'avessero fatto
a me probabilmente avrebbe rimediato
soltanto delle carte di brioche degli
scontrini credo invece di essermi perso
la vie di mezzo quel tipo di bullo che
non ha abbastanza soldi per escluderti
psicologicamente ma team era comunque
perché sono comunque molto premurosi
ma quali sono le motivazioni dietro le
loro azioni gli esperti in televisione
dicono tutti la stessa cosa può essere
individui hanno tutti una situazione
familiare difficile e scusa se lo dicono
quelli della televisione vuol dire che è
fermo beh a volte davvero così normale
che la violenza domestica associata ad
un adolescenza non proprio brillante
possano far sfogare il ragazzo e
trasformano in un bullo poi non villa in
dotato di superpoteri che vuole
distruggere gotham o in un rapper si a
volte così io personalmente però ho
visto anche gente a tornare a casa da
una famiglia benestante normalissima e
come si spiega allora il figlio stronzo
ve lo dico io perché gli piace fare così
come a me piace mangiare le penne al
ragù a lui piace far sentire inferiore
il prossimo ai genitori che dovrebbero
essere la figura di riferimento nonché
fulcro della sua educazione cosa diranno
mai di questi comportamenti simas ai
ragazzi grandissimo pezzo di stronzo
tralasciando il fatto che ci sarà un
posto all'inferno per gente di merda
come voi
seduti vicino a hitler a guardare per
l'eternità le repliche del bagaglino se
non sai fare il genitore ti regalo una
scatola formato famiglia di preservativi
e tenetevi pure per le prossime
generazioni è ma sai crescere i figli
non è facile
molto probabilmente no ma risponde una
domanda perché tu non sei capace quindi
ci deve dimettere il figlio di qualcun
altro verso ragazzi un paio di cazzi
però se avete notato non solo loro
quelli che fanno uccidere la gente o no
c'è un altro
molto più potente e molto più spaventoso
di tutti gli altri
internet ci sarebbe un bello slogan
sotto internet perché lo schermo non
serve solo a partire per le cose ma
anche a nascondere la faccia da culo di
alcune persone i leoni da tastiera solo
un numero infinito è in continua
crescita che può rovinare la vita di una
persona senza manco accorgersene
mettiamo caso che una ragazza mandi le
sue foto seminuda al fidanzato dai non
dite di no le vorremmo tutti e poi per
aver sbagliato un tasto queste foto
vadano online pubbliche sotto gli occhi
di tutti che tra l'altro è una cosa
quasi esclusivamente maschile non ho mai
sentito di una ragazza con le foto dei
testicoli del proprio ragazzo sul
cellulare e qui eravamo in e noi allo
zoo qui nemico la giraffa qui è un
elefante con problemi basta un attimo
che un paio di decerebrati qualsiasi
crino una pagina con quelle fotografie
su facebook e tutto crolla la ragazza si
vergogni a tal punto da non riuscire
neanche a uscire di casa e tra l'altro
quando si parla neanche più di legge
della natura che solo il più forte
sopravvive o cagate del genere no questa
è una cosa al cento per cento umana
quindi ringraziamo ancora una volta
l'umanità per averci regalato un'altra
delle sue perle il cyberbullismo
grazie umanità grazie mille oppure
ancora sta storia dei gay
quante volte quante volte è successo che
nei ragazzi insultarsi loro compagno
omosessuale che magari gli facessero una
foto per scherzo con photoshop
questa foto andasse su internet il
ragazzo si vergogni e magari si butta
anche giù da un cazzo di balcone durante
lo porca [ __ ] nel 2014 l'unico motivo
per cui potresti odiare un gay
e se un serial killer omosessuale ha
stuprato la tua famiglia e gli ha
tagliato
con un machete allora li di ne yo che
c'ha ragione lui ma guardi quello
veramente io non concepisco
anzi vi invito a vedere un video di
carlo gabardini sull'argomento chiamato
la marmellata e la nutella troverete il
link nelle tifo è tutto questo cumulo di
luoghi comuni e banalità che ho appena
detto l'ho detto per un motivo ben
preciso ho una buona fetta di gente che
ogni giorno mi scrive queste cose quindi
questo video lo rivolgo a voi se per
caso vi doveste trovare in queste
situazioni stringete i denti non vi dico
nulla del genere tipo ignora lì non
pensarci perché la gente che dice queste
cose qua non ha idea di cosa può passare
un'altra persona non dipende da lei ci
sono alcune persone che riescono a
migliorare e altre no.ma ma la
situazione migliorerà
non sono né uno psicologo è né un
genitore quindi prendete le mie parole
per quelle che sono però vi posso
assicurare che non sarà così per molto
tempo
cercate di non tenerli dentro nuclei
parlate ogni volta che potete con
qualcuno anche se una cosa di cui vi
vergognate tanto state tranquilli che
non siete poi quelli che si dovrebbero
vergognare
quindi io vi chiedo una domanda
banalissima proprietà di uno mattina
siete mai stati vittima di bullismo ma
soprattutto ancora meglio chi è stato
vittima di bullismo anni fa e ormai l'ha
superata potrebbe raccontare se vuole la
sua esperienza e di come ha affrontato
quegli anni magari anche molto duri
e poi voglio dire se sono sopravvissuto
io con questa capigliatura potete star
tranquilli che non siete così male
[Applauso]
[Musica]